- When we asked who you
wanted to see on Sound Field,
this is what you said.
(noise music)
In the world of avant-garde music,
historians mostly talk about
white man's contributions
to the genre.
Oftentimes overlooking the
presence and musical offerings
of the LGBTQ, black and POC artists.
We wanna explore noise music, its origins
and the underrepresented
artists who create noise
and experimental music.
One of those artists is the rising
underground musician Dreamcrusher.
- I should make this very clear.
I mainly call myself a noise musician
because white people hate when I do that.
My music's a bunch of different stuff.
You could like classify it as noise,
but I'm really not into the
whole genre purism thing.
I think it's really whack.
- My usual co-host Nahre Sol
is off working on her album.
So I asked musician and
vocalist Linda Diaz to meet up
with Dreamcrusher in New York city.
(noise music)
- Who comes to your shows?
And if it is a lot of
like black queer people
and or artists, how does
that influence them?
Or how do you feel
like that impacts them at your shows?
- Historically with punk shows
or noise shows or whatever.
So many queer people
and just young people in POC,
like don't feel comfortable.
(noise music)
Like a lot of queer kids
come to my shows now.
It is nice to like say that you're a thing
and people who are also
that thing feel affirmed
by it and show up and show their face
to you and tell you how
your work affected them.
That's like, it's amazing.
And it gives more meaning
to the work, which is cool.
(noise music)
- So what is noise music?
Noise is hard to define
and most people agree
that it's subjective.
As music theorist Torben Sangild put it,
"What is noise to one person
can be meaningful to another;
what was considered an unpleasant
sound yesterday is not today."
The term noise dates back
to 1913 when futurist artist
and musician Luigi Russolo published
his groundbreaking manifesto,
'The Art of Noises'.
Russolo said that the
industrial revolution created
an entirely new landscape
of sounds to explore.
The noises of metal screeching
and the construction
of skyscrapers gave listeners a
greater capacity to experience new sounds.
Another influence on
composes of the era was
World Wars one and two.
Life was a lot bleaker back then
which led a lot of musicians
and composers to experiment
and move away from melodic music.
Since then, the genre has been shaped
by art movements such
as Dada and Surrealism.
One of the greatest influences
in noise has been the Fluxus movement.
These artists emphasize
the artistic process
over the finished product.
Listen to Ben Patterson's paper piece
which was created by giving
five performers pieces of paper
and directions on how to
crumble, scrub, and twist them.
Ben Patterson, a black
artist born in 1934 was one
of the co-founders of the Fluxus movement.
But his contributions are
often overlooked for his peers
like Yoko Ono and John Cage.
This gets us back to
Dreamcrusher, performing
at Saint Vitus bar in Brooklyn, New York.
(noise music)
What does your music sound like
or how do you make a song?
- There was this kid that
like, had never gone to a show
of mine before that like walked up to me.
It was probably in Philly.
I feel like kids are a
lot more vocal in Philly.
Then he walks up to me and he goes,
"That sounded like a plane crashing
for like half an hour."
(noise music)
I make all my music mainly on a computer.
More recently I've been
using a lot more samples.
Yeah I make like 90%
of my own sound effects
and stuff like that.
I just downloaded a program.
Honestly I still don't
know what I'm doing.
I just like mess with stuff.
And then like, hopefully
it comes out right.
- What program did you start on?
Like, was it like a garage band situation?
Was it like a phone,
voice note type thing?
I still do most of my vocals on my phone.
I still use FL Studio for
literally the first 12 years
that I made anything.
It was the trial version
and I couldn't save anything.
And then if I like,
didn't like how it came
out I would like just do it again.
(noise music)
Dreamcrusher's ability to record,
distribute, and design
their own handmade tapes
and albums, perform hundreds of shows
and create heavily nuanced
soundscapes with socially
and politically charged
lyrics has made them a staple
in the world of postmodern noise music.
- I mean, put it like this
like, one of the times we played together
and Allusive saw you, was
just like, Oh, it sounds
like a planet is being born.
And I was like, yeah, yes.
- That's what he said?
- Yeah.
But essentially, yeah,
you were a world builder
and also just like a
sweet, like projecting
of love type of person.
You know what I mean?
Like there was a genuine sort of sense
in your spirit and what not, so.
(noise music)
- Like when you first moved
to New York, how many
shows were you playing?
- Oh yeah, oh yeah.
I've played like, I
think 108 shows in 2015
when I first moved here.
- [Linda] What!
- I didn't have a place to
live and whoever I was playing
with, I would just like,
hey, anybody got a couch?
And I was like sleeping at
Penn station for a little bit.
It was like, that was a mess.
But like I made it to shows on time,
did sound check and everything like, ay.
- [Linda] Do a lot of people think
of you as like the first
to do what you're doing?
- I think a lot of people think
that, or it's the first
time they've seen somebody
like me make it.
And that's a lie.
(noise music)
Although Dreamcrusher
exerts their strong beliefs
on individualism in their music and art.
They also consider themselves to be a part
of a community of black, POC
and queer noise musicians.
They told the fader,
"I always ask people
to research the history
of people of color in noise
and queer people in noise.
People aren't paying attention to that.
So my main mission is that I
want people to stop treating me
like I'm an anomaly.
Because I'm not."
One of Dreamcrushers musical influences
is the renowned Japanese
noise artist Merzbow.
Since the 70s and 1980s, Japan has been a
leading creator of noise music.
So much so that the
music scene inspired its
own sub-genre called Japanoise.
Music Journalist Cleary Mallard writes,
"Noise takes it further
than any other genre.
Rhythm, melody, lyrics,
standard instruments:
all forgotten... Across the world
people experiment with this
style, but Japanoise was one
of the greatest catalysts
for its existence today."
Fans like Hijokaiden
and Melt-Banana thrashed
into the North American
music lexicon creating
a globalized alternative,
and more importantly, a level
of equality with white
noise bands like Sonic Youth
and Psychic TV.
Dreamcrusher was even featured
on a compilation curated by
Adult Swim, entitled 'noise'
alongside the music of
Merzbow and Melt-Banana.
But wait, the connection runs even deeper.
Masami Akita of Merzbow and Dreamcrusher
are both influenced by
free-jazz and the other worldly
music experimentalists Sun Ra.
(jazz music)
Free-Jazz is a form of
tonal experimentation
which approaches jazz improvisation
in unconventional ways
such as deconstructing chords and tempos
to create discordant
compositions in the 1950s
and 1960s.
Artists like Albert Ayler, Cecil Taylor,
and poet and musician,
Amiri Baraka, all rejected
traditional jazz composition
to map new territory
and open doors for experimental
black artists to rebel
against resonant, syncopated,
politically neutral music.
Instead, these artists spoke their minds
about the times they were living in.
The rise of modern recording
and sound processing
techniques, specifically
distortion also influenced
the development of
electronic and noise music.
An example of this is the
practice Musique Concrete.
Where the composer edits
and distorts recorded
sounds to make a piece of music.
Listen to 'Wings of The Delirious Demon'
by Ilhan Mimaroglu, composed
by manipulating the pitch
of a clarinet recording.
The invention of the Moog synthesizer
in 1964 was a breakthrough
for experimental musicians.
These instruments are
the precursors to a lot
of computer generated
sounds heard in experimental
and noise music.
The instrument was brought
into the mainstream
by transgender artist,
Wendy Carlos and her album
'Switched-On Bach' in 1968.
She later went on to produce
synthesize soundtracks
for Stanley Kubrick's 'Clockwork
Orange' and 'The Shining'.
So how were you inspired by Wendy Carlos?
- My mom's a big cinephile and
one of the first like movies
from like her era was 'Clockwork Orange'.
It's so sick to see like something
like that, because, so I don't know.
I just, almost every other
image of music I ever saw was
like people playing real instruments.
- New York's downtown music
scene was also an influence
on the formation of noise music.
Set off by Yoko Ono in
1960 when she opened
her downtown loft for
unconventional music performances.
The live music downtown differed
from the more traditional
classical music played uptown
by the Lincoln Center.
One of the musicians of
New York's downtown scene
what's minimalist
composer, Julius Eastman.
A lot of his avant-garde
compositions focused
on his identity as a black queer man.
Why do your fans love you so much?
Why do they love your music?
(noise music)
- I hope it's because they
escaped through my work.
I hope that it's because I provide
something very unique musically for them.
(noise music)
I don't see a lot of black
non binary people like being
in Pitchfork and Stereogum
like on NPR or PBS.
(laughing)
But like, I hope that like, people seeing
me will like open the, not open
the flood gates necessarily.
Cause hey, they ain't that
many of us, but there's enough
of us to like, come on.
- Do you feel like it is a political act,
the art that you make,
or you as an artist?
- I'm just making things
that make me happy.
If that's what it takes to
affirm other black queer artists
or people of color who want to make
something that they didn't grow up around
or like get any affirmation from it.
And it's like, all right, like I want
to like be able to make
space for them too.
(noise music)
Sound Field finally has a
Patreon where you can support us.
Get behind the scenes concert
footage and early access
to every new episode
Link in the description.
One last thing before I go,
we do a survey every year
that helps us make more
of the stuff you want to see.
You even get to vote
on potential new shows.
Find the link below and
tell them Sound Field
is your favorite.